let's start with the good stuff
let's start with the good stuff so what
are the pros
of dating a and what i'm saying dating
like i'm not saying like you know she's
a plate she's the friends with benefits
like i'm talking about like you're
dating
uh maybe you're in a long-term
relationship maybe you're considering
having children with her
you know at a later date but what are
the pros of
inviting a professional woman into your
life in your view
yeah so so and let me give a little
context here because you know with
dating
i assume that you're you're wanting all
of the benefits
of the messing around in the hookup
phase right so you're wanting some of
those benefits
so you know some of the benefits and
i've seen this with a lot of lawyers
myself and
and you know i'll give this little
little stamp here i was you know engaged
to a lawyer but also i've dated
many many lawyers so i'm definitely my
area of expertise and also professional
women in general doctors
accountants etc um the one thing about
professional women is
they all have to be driven and because
of that often times now not always
there's some of them that
do not take care of themselves but some
of them are competitive and some of them
do
have the money to invest in surgery some
of them can look good they can get the
honkers and they can pay for that right
you know so they're enhanced they're
enhanced
some of them go some of them are
competitive and go to the gym because
they're they're that type of personality
that
that you know female alpha personality
a laugh whenever women call themselves
alpha but i'm an alpha female
get ready to be consumed but um you know
they can't have that where they put
themselves together they also here's a
pro they have money so they are not
looking necessarily
necessarily to leech off yours but put a
pin in that we'll come back to that
the last thing is more of a fallacy but
you have to understand that this is
something that almost
every guy falls into almost every guy
has been told the lie
that you want somebody who's similar to
you who has similar interests right
who wants to do the exact same things as
you right and because
of who they are and also because of the
fact they've been in a masculine
environment and we'll talk about that
but because they've been in that
environment they like bro stuff
so a lot of times they'll do shots with
you at the bar right you'll go out and
they'll drink whiskey with you
they'll go with you and your boys the
club or the
adult club if you want to you know a lot
of times they'll be down but
you've got to understand that is not
necessarily a benefit and if you really
are taking
the rp that is really a drawback but
those are things i think people perceive
as pros to um
to professionals do you have any others
rich that you would want to add to that
list um
yeah i would pretty much co-sign what
you're saying so to sort of kind of like
throw my perspective on it um
you generally don't need to babysit them
like you do
with some other women i'm not saying
that like in a disparaging way but
like they're more competent in the sense
of real life because they
i mean the thing with professional women
is they get into these professions
and they tend to compete in the space
they compete with a lot of men
in the legal profession for example in
law firms it's mostly male
dominated but what ends up happening
with a lot of women
for now but what ends up happening with
a lot of women um
when it comes to law is they typically
go and work at the law firms they might
become an associate
some will work all the way up to
partners i don't know what the
structure is in the u.s is it is it
associate partnership exactly like that
so
it's a pyramid right so at the bottom of
the pyramid or well i guess the bottom
you could say is that you're basically
the fodder you're just like a new guy
you get to do all the research yes
associate your fodder new guy and then
you have your juniors
junior partners and your senior partners
your senior partners
yeah juniors are usually mid middle age
i mean even your age rich would be a
junior partner
you know you could still be a junior
partner which is scary and then you got
your fossils
that are the senior partners that are
there just crystallizing
while they leave waiting for somebody to
like fall off so they can become an
official partner yeah exactly and and
that's just what happens in that but
it's still it is a pyramid scheme
yeah okay so it's a pyramid scheme but i
mean
one of the things is that they behave a
lot like men um
they dress in clothing that is quite
masculine like
i did a lot of lawyers and they used to
wear like the padded shoulders
you know like this you know stuff like
the suit that andrew's got on with the
padded shoulders and
but it's got the skirt bottom so um it's
not
it's not it's weird because it's like
you've got what are generally feminine
women
dress in a hybrid version of a male
outfit with some feminine touches like a
skirt with a bunch of makeup and hair
and all that sort of stuff and some
enhancements in some cases
more so probably miami than what yeah
yeah yeah
i didn't see that many enhancements here
if i'm being honest i saw them in other
professions and fields but i get
you know what you're saying but yeah so
um they can stand on their own two feet
they usually have a house they have
their own car
uh they don't need to get picked up and
dropped off they'll you know they'll
meet you or they'll come over to your
place
um so yeah there are some benefits to it
um
one of the things that i kind of kind of
just stumbled on
when i was dating my ex-wife was she
brought up the topic of a prenup
and i was always you know cautious about
you know how do i talk about this how do
you bring up the
conversation of a prenup and she's just
like uh yeah i got my life sorted so
you're gonna need to sign a prenup i'm
like
yes i don't even need to bring it up
so um yeah so there are some upsides to
dating professional women because they
usually have their stuff together
um are there any other upsides that we
missed so i mean i think one that i just
want to like double down on that you
said is the time thing because i think
if you're a guy out there who's trying
to play to win this is what we can trap
you
right um you know that's why it's before
the train wreck right yeah um
so you know the time thing because with
you i know rich you are one of the guys
who guards your time
jealously you are very strict with it
and i think that's a practice that more
people should adopt
i mean because frankly the more you do
that the more you're effective the more
you're efficient the more your
discipline the more you have a goal and
you're focused right
um but i think you're lured in by the
fact that these girls don't require a
lot of your time in fact they're so busy
uh lawyers they're billing right we bill
every six minutes right
one of an hour right we're billing that
right so they understand time they
understand efficiency they understand
you know getting to the point right
you'll probably get to delay pretty
quickly right you're not going to waste
too much time with that
with these folks but once again
that is also in a way a trap because you
know
looking at the similarity we'll put a
pin in that put a pin in that they're
they're they're um
they're quite smart you know they're
cutting um they're able to solve
problems woody banter yeah woody banter
uh
less emotional still still you know can
be quite emotional but less emotional
than the average chick
um they're also a lot more professional
so you're not going to see
like you know professional women showing
their butthole on only fans or tic-tock
right so you're not going to have to
deal with that that much
and not as many outbursts that are kind
of crazy right you're not going to have
an outburst like a trailer trash woman
yeah you know yeah you know so or drug
issues or other things
other than uh you know the typical uh
maybe the adderall down here or the the
you know maybe cocaine or something
that's a stimulant
because they gotta get all that work
done yeah but generally speaking they're
like
not bad people i just
like today for me it's not a good match
on a long-term relationship
and you know we'll get into why with the
uh
you know the the con part there's um
there's a chat here and i want to hit on
moffs over here because a friend of mine
from the community says it's my
understanding that professional women
are some of the most submissive you'll
find in the bedroom
um do you want me to do you want me to
open on that dream
let me say this you know she's a woman
so setting aside the profession she's
still a woman
okay so she's gonna follow if you're
able to lead so let's just put it that
way what do you think andrew
yeah and here's another thing and i'll
tell you this about a lot of jobs this
will right this is a red pill for you
um if the job requires you to be
very very dominant a lot of the day a
lot of times especially women they want
the opposite right
so for example if they're in a position
where they're you know extraordinarily
subservient sometimes they'll come home
and try to assert that
but with with those women especially
some professional women they've never
seen somebody like that they've never
seen it so they're kind of thirsty for
it in a lot of ways so
sometimes they will but also you got to
understand they're not submissive for
anybody
for they're not definitely not for you
know beta males or people they view as
you know kind of beneath them but for
the right guy for the right guy and it
could be you
the right guy uh they will actually be
submissive yes
you